[Musique]
allez attention on va accueillir tout de
suite est ce que vous connaissez
françois valéry ayvaz exactement
aimons-nous vivant
nous vivons disons c'est c'est pour
qu'elle enquête après qu'un rapport
j'ai passé un de laquelle raffut rui
mondial on voyait qu'il est blond il
cherche l'amour est laid se demande
d'ailleurs où sont les femmes
intrigues buvette avec à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les toits
là
il est un peu habillée comme comme à dax
tu sais cette beauté on va cueillir
maintenant les faux rebonds sont les
rois du rock and roll
[Musique]
m
quelques mois
je
sam est à fond les deux est ce qu on a
fait tout ça pour vous donc la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser est ce que
ça vous fait plaisir
génial génial
non vraiment on a fait tout ça moi je
connais les originaux tu comprendrais
quand je vois ça je rigole ça oui alors
là il faut que tu vas bien faire ce
qu'on accueille sheila et ringo
[Musique]
il
on les suit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça va pas bien au moral à ses
gondoles à venise et vous allez à ces
votes reçus pour mon vestiaire c'est
catherine lara a malheureusement c'est
gilles verdez
c'est la banque
le diamant
monsieur là
dix autres avaient peu à peu du bien aux
questions c'est vrai je trouve hyper
beau c'est gentil france gall à
problèmes vous vous n'êtes pas france
gall non pas physiquement à lui
recherché la joue mieux
si vous êtes spacer eux non on a changé
parce que aller mieux à la personne
d'après je suis là spacer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
c'est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
matthieu delormeau
est ce que voulait vraiment marrant
non allez au parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui